these exceptions to the rule but the
reason that I came up with those three
tenants is the field of personal finance
is I think very confusing and
overwhelming to people if you look on
amazon if you do a search for personal
finance there are literally 20,000 books
written on personal finance and there's
no real reason for it I mean personal
finance is pretty simple you see content
on the internet whether it's CNN Money
The Motley Fool even give a mint blog in
in in some ways and fundamentally it can
all boil down all those books all those
articles to three basic principles which
you name spend less than you earn which
means basically save money make the
money you have work for you which means
invest it and then be prepared for the
unexpected which means you know protect
your downside with the right types of
insurance with diversification of your
investments and so the first aspect is
save it and the best thing to do there
is to set a budget on your problem
categories if you've lost your job than
saving money shouldn't be your primary
concern should be finding another job
and making ends meet the other thing
that you can do to save money without
really changing your behavior is to
optimize your financial accounts so most
people seem to have the checking and
savings account they set up when they
were 16 or 17 you went into your local
bank with your mom and you set up the
checking account and you're not being
paid any interest and if you have a
savings account from citibank Wells
Fargo Bank of America any of the
big-name banks I guarantee that right
now you're being paid between 0.1
percent and 0.2 percent interest which
is ridiculous because you can make two
percent interest right now and if
interest rates go up fed changes the
rates you could make three four or five
percent interest you're going to be
earning a fifth to a tenth as much at
most of the big banks as you could
either get at a credit union or an
internet bank like ing or HSBC or
emigrant direct bank or ally bank which
is the old gmac actually pays
the best interest rates around right now
I'm a big big fan and they have accounts
without any fees so if you optimize your
financial accounts get a high-yield
savings account put your deposits in
there get a credit card that if you're
paying interest on your credit card is
at a lower rate if you pay your credit
card off every month get a rewards card
one that gives you airline miles or that
will give you one percent cash back at
least on every purchase some of them
will still give you three to five
percent back on restaurants or groceries
or gas or whatever that type of card is
I use an American Express blue cash card
and after you've spent about six
thousand dollars on that card it'll give
you five percent on gas and restaurants
and it means I've made so far this year
about five hundred dollars cash back
it's great and then you know
consolidating your student loans or
finding in even a brokerage account if
you're an active trader that you're
going to spend less on your your cost
per trade all of those things don't
really require a change in your
day-to-day behavior they just require
being a little smarter about which
financial accounts you should have